monsieur à berthen bienvenu merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors fermeture
d'orly au moins jusqu'à l'automne c'est
la décision qui semble se dessiner en ce
moment bah c'est une décision au fait
qui est prise surtout par rapport au
niveau de trafic c'est pas un problème
de sur décision gouvernementale j'allais
dire c'est surtout le niveau de trafic
qui déterminera le la rouverture d'orly
effectivement qu'on les avait dit
aujourd'hui cdg avec le terminal les
terminaux e et f a et celle ouverte il
suffit à accueillir le trafic ce qui va
surtout dépendre c'est des conditions de
reprise du trafic dont voulait il
voulait pas du tourisme effectivement d
un comité interministériel qui doit
avoir lieu le 14 mai pour déjà au niveau
national savoir comment ça se passait et
puis on attend si surtout au niveau de
recontre au café au niveau des mesures
sanitaires européennes qui seront mises
en place qui devrait être comme une part
pour tous des états c'est une des
conditions aussi dures plus arides au
niveau européen dans un premier temps
justement il est dit que certaines
compagnies aériennes ne respecterait pas
la distanciation social qui est de
rigueur en ce moment est ce que c'est
vraiment le cas moi je suis pas
compagnies aériennes est ce que c'est le
cas je ne serais pas pour moi j'ai vu
que c'est la française c'était le cas
pour ce qui concerne en tout les cas le
lait les vols qui sont maîtres qui sont
opérés uniquement pas la france à un
niveau 2 de cdg ce qui va être surtout
importance et c'est surtout par la suite
ces mesures qui vont être mises en place
pour savoir effectivement dans quelles
conditions on pourra voyager les
voyageurs et passagers et c'est la
garantie d'une reprise du trafic
effectivement alors c'est la grande
question qui se pose actuellement on n'a
toujours pas de précision là dessus il
n'y a aucune annonce n'a été faite c'est
un peu la certitude et c'est peut-être
là où on est en attente
effectivement des décisions qui seront
prenez vos nations en tous les cas mais
quand je voulais dit il nous semble
qu'il est primordial qu au niveau
européen il ya des mesures communes
qu'ils soient prises sinon ce serait on
irait vers un système
à différents différé différentes étapes
différentes manoeuvres d etat s sas et
ça complique alors oui ce trafic et les
niveaux trafic sera très différent il
faut se baser un peu sur ce qui a été
fait j'allais dire pour le suite aux
attaques terroristes dans l'est dans les
aéroports les mesures communes qui ont
été mises en place c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut qu'on soit prêt nous à faire
justement selon vous savez dire que les
bras nouvelles façons de voyager après
le déconfinement bah oui certainement
bien sûr ça c'est c'est sûr que c'est
nous voyageons qui savourait ce que sera
moyen terme
je pense qu'il faut peut-être il faut
sans doute réfléchir
effectivement comment on va voyager de
man et comment on va adapter notre
industrie aéronautique
et puis les métiers qui en découlent moi
ce que j'entends c'est c'est pas faux
pas les faux pas de pessimistes et dire
c'est la fin de tout justement on l'a on
a l'occasion de se préparer à ça il faut
préparer nos esprits et nos métiers a
évolué sur des mesures qui peut être
mise en place mais si c'est fait avec un
accompagnement et pourrait s'il n'y a
pas de raison de s'inquiéter ce qui est
l'inquiétude séquence est brutal et
quand c'est pas concertés or aujourd'hui
on a on a un peu on a le temps d'y
réfléchir
et ça aussi ça fait partie des
conditions parce que le qu'on y parle de
confiance dans le voyage il faut aussi
penser aux salariés moi je pense d'abord
à eux les conditions de confiance pour
exercer son métier et pouvoir aussi
évoluer dans dans nos professions il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire et je pense
que je suis certain qu'il savait où
beaucoup de propositions à faire pour
aussi trouver les réponses aux
problématiques qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui daniel berten merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général cgt des
aéroports de paris merci